the next day woke up and thought oh my
god this is sitting in my room so I
decided to go and get the statue
so it's this bustling area and I'll tell
you
it was really busy and pretty crazy
I'd look at the statues about how big
they were so I had to fit a kilo into it
uh eventually found one which was
perfect
I had to also buy some partying that
would steal it and any gold paint
as soon as they got back to my
guesthouse I went to check the suitcase
was alright no one had tried to get into
it it was the relief that was still
securely lot
I waited till midnight cuz I wanted to
do it when I wouldn't have anyone
knocking on the door there was no one
around the first thing I did was put the
gloves on so they wouldn't have my
finger prints if the parcel did get
seized in Europe I pulled out of the bed
it looks so much hat dawned on me that I
was actually doing this
yes
I've started removing the cling film
because it had to be molded to put into
the statue the smell hit me it was quite
pungent
took a long time to take the cling film
off because every single piece was
wrapped in it my gender is definitely
flow
I put a couple of lumps in my house and
put it inside the statue at the bottom
just to press it down I was thinking oh
my god if my mother could see me now
what am i doing
my heart was pumping
just wanted it to be done so I could
seal it up once it was sealed no one
would know it was in there took me about
three hours
when it was all finished off just relief
it was done it looked like a bottom
match arrested statute it was probably
about 4:00 in the morning so I was quite
tired because my brain had been working
overtime by lay down thinking I don't
know if I'm gonna sleep